- But first I want to
introduce a busy mom of two,
who recently reached out to me,
check out the video she sent us.
- Hi Kelly, I have a two
year old named Ellie,
and a two month old named Mason,
so you can imagine these last two months,
have been absolutely crazy.
Mommy hasn't have any time,
except running for an hour to target,
to get some more diapers, and wipes,
and anything else these kids need.
If I had a day off,
I would love to actually
take off this mom bun,
that I've been rocking for
about two years, and do my hair,
go to restaurant, enjoy a hot meal,
enjoy it before it's cold,
because I'm not sharing
it with my two year old,
or nursing my two month old,
actually gonna eat it and enjoy it.
Anyways, I hope you have
a wonderful new show,
congratulations on it, can't
wait to watch it everyday.
Take care, bye!
(audience clapping)
- So, here's the thing,
I'm actually still trying
to find the problem
with what she said because
I often go to target,
to get my children-
I often wear a mom bun
everyday of my life.
When I say often, I mean everyday,
except for when I'm at work.
It's fine Ashley, you're fine.
But, Ashley asked us for some help,
so I enlisted someone
pretty amazing to help her.
Please welcome mom, actress,
and the genius behind The Honest Company,
Jessica Alba y'all, come on!
(audience cheering)
(inspirational music)
I love this dress!
- Thank you.
- Yes, come on over here.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh!
- Hi!
- I love her!
(audience cheering)
Jessica's my first guest today,
but she came early to help Ashley.
When I say early, I mean
she's been here all day.
- True story.
- I love her, like true
story, been here all day.
Like since this morning.
- It's amazing here!
- I love it here!
- I'm not gonna leave.
- Okay, I love it.
We will come up with a segment girl,
don't you threaten me
with a good time, okay.
Tell everyone why you
wanted to help Ashley,
'cause I think this is awesome.
- Yeah, so I wanted to
help Ashley because,
I have three kids myself, and
I found that after I had kids,
and going back to work,
it's really hard to find,
time for me to pamper myself.
And when I take the time to
pamper myself and to feel good,
I feel like I'm a better person,
I'm showing up better everyday.
And I feel like someone
who has spent so much time,
like she has, dedicated to her family,
and she just had a two month
old, she has a two year old.
- It's a lot.
- It's a lot, and they're babies,
and they need a lot of her.
Not only are they physically
depleting her body,
but, you know, mentally.
- Love nursing (laughing)
- You know?
But also like, the lack of sleep,
and all the things to go with it.
So I was like let's give her
a day where she feels loved,
and pampered, and that's what-
- [Kelly] And it's about her.
- And it's about her.
- I love that!
(audience clapping)
You're like the greatest
human, I love you.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I'm so excited you came here
today, and this is no lie,
one, I was excited to meet you,
but also, I have the worst
allergies with makeup.
- Oh.
- No, no like it's real.
Because you have a whole new makeup line.
- Yeah so, I do.
(audience cheering)
I have all the allergies,
I get rashes like you wouldn't believe.
I would have cystic acne
is what I thought I had.
- Me too, I did have that.
- You know, basically from like age 12,
until I stopped working full
time, and I was pregnant.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was like, "oh wait,
maybe it's just the makeup
they're putting on me everyday."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's what it was.
- I'm excited to use the
makeup, I'm being real.
- Aww, thank you.
- I cannot wait.
And I hope it's helpful.
- I can't wait for you to try it
- Well we've got a clip of
Jessica surprising Ashley,
y'all take a look.
(happy music)
- Okay guys, I am about to
pull Ashley out of the line,
for a surprise make over.
This should be fun.
Almost as fun as me matching this wall.
(upbeat music)
- Hi.
(crowd cheering)
- Hi, Ashley?
- Yeah!
- I'm Jessica.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too!
Will you come with me?
- Yeah!
- We have a surprise for you.
- Okay.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- You're very trusting,
just coming with a stranger.
- Well you look nice.
- Into a mysterious place.
(happy music)
Do you know why you're here?
- Um, kind of-
Not why I'm sitting here with you.
No, I don't know why I'm sitting
here with you. (laughing)
- So we are going to give you a make over.
(crowd cheering)
When was the last time
you pampered yourself?
- Before I was pregnant
with my son. (laughing)
- [Jessica] Oh my goodness.
I have a brand of beauty
product, skin care, and makeup.
And so I will be your
personal makeup artist.
- That's amazing.
- Do you trust me?
- Yeah, I think so. (laughing)
- Cool, let's do this!
- All right!
(crowd cheering)
- Ashley's mom Rosie is in
our audience, are you ready?
Mrs. Rosie, are you ready?
- Yes.
- Are you ready to see Ashley's new look?
- [Mrs. Rosie] Yes, I'm excited.
- Yes, okay cool.
There's nothing wrong with a mom bun,
but okay let's remind everyone,
what Ashley looked like
when she got here today.
All right, all right!
Come on out here Ashley!
(crowd cheering)
- Girl!
- Whoa!
- Don't cry! (laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Whoo!
- [Kelly] You look amazing, no lie!
- Aww!
So wait!
- You look so beautiful!
- [Kelly] You look so
beautiful, wait how do you feel?
How do you feel?
- Amazing, I just saw
myself for the first time,
right now looking at that monitor.
- I know!
That's you, you're super hot!
- (laughing) I can't believe it!
- [Kelly] Yes!
(crowd cheering)
So you created Ashley's
entire look, tell us about it.
- So you know, she's
32, she's super young,
and you know, I feel like
when you become a mom,
is when you really step into yourself,
and your sexiness, your
sassiness, and your fierceness-
- Whole lot of women.
- All the things,
and I just wanted her
to look on the outside,
how she feels on the inside.
And this is the, you know,
the version of her that I can see.
And you look beautiful!
- Thank you!
- I mean, I love the before photo too.
I think you hot-
I look like a mom bun everyday of my life,
when I'm not working.
- Same, same story.
- It's also nice to dress
up every once in a while,
and be like, "okay, I clean up all right."
Yes, you look so beautiful, okay.
Where did you learn to do makeup?
You're really good.
- [Ashley] Yeah she's good.
- Do you do your own
when you act and stuff?
Like wow.
- Sometimes.
- Okay.
- I was basically-
My mom went to cosmetology
school when I was little,
and so I was her Barbie head.
And like basically how I
bonded with my mom growing up,
was we used to like get ready
to go out, wherever it was.
And it was always the getting
ready that was more fun,
than wherever we went.
- Oh my gosh, we're so different.
(both laughing)
- And my mom's a good
time, she made margaritas,
and hanging out, and yeah
my mom's a good time.
- Kind of sound like
torture to me as a kid,
but I love that you loved it.
You have a two year old, right?
Girl, right?
- She's already gotten into the makeup.
- [Kelly] So she's into it,
- Yes.
- she's into it, okay, okay.
We'll come closer to you,
we didn't want to take up your
space of looking beautiful.
But we'll come closer now.
- [Jessica] Does mom want
to come up and say hi?
- [Kelly] Come on Rosie, come on up here.
(crowd cheering)
- She made me cry,
because I looked at her.
- Isn't it awesome, she looks beautiful!
- [Ashley] Don't cry! (laughing)
I'll start ugly crying. (laughing)
She worked really hard on this,
I don't want to mess it up.
- Turn around here,
let's back up and move,
so everybody can see
your beautiful selves.
- So what do you think?
- [Kelly] What do you think, Rosie?
You think she looks beautiful?
- She's always beautiful no matter what.
- Good answer.
- Yeah she really is.
Okay, here's my question for you.
Because I can only imagine getting a call,
and like, you wake up in the morning,
and their like,
"So Jessica Alba is gonna
be doing your makeup."
Like even me, right now, I
would've been like, "Okay."
I would've been like, "Let's do it guys!"
- I mean even as she was doing it,
first, I never would've thought
it would happen in a million years.
I would've made a million
guesses, and never said that.
But when I'm sitting back
there, as she's doing it,
I'm just sitting there, "I'm
in a dream, this is not real."
I still feel like I'm
in a dream right now,
this isn't happening.
- And also she's like a huge fan of yours,
and she's been to a few of your-
- Yeah I'm trying to be a
little bit cool right now.
- Few of your concerts.
- Oh my gosh!
- She knows every words of your songs.
- You are being so chill right now.
- I heard you in the halls,
and I was like, (gasp)
- I know, I didn't want to
see you, I saw the paper,
and they weren't letting
you look at yourself,
and I was so excited-
- [Ashley] I froze, I was like-
- I should've said "hi"
now, now I feel like a jerk.
But we're saying "hi" now.
Okay, I'm like wait.
I was trying to keep the suspense, but-
- And I'm trying to keep
my cool, so. (laughing)
- You're doing really, really well.
And you know what, y'all can
recreate this look at home,
because everyone is going
home with a gift bag,
filled with Honest Beauty products.